hallo an herzen kommen zur bekannt gibt
es kein projekt wir haben schon vor
einiger zeit ist also damit kommt öfter
in dieser tv-show oder pc infiziert
gesagt dass er bald ein geheimes projekt
und ziemlich viel lieber wenn dabei sein
hier seht ihr gerade alle bis auf so
nicht alle die dabei sind also es sind
dabei den mhd minecraft freunde com
crafter hallo minecraft freunde
hallo minecraft freunde nicht doch uns
einig dass wir haben jetzt einen termin
sozusagen gesucht um ein bisschen was
darüber ist quatsch wird ziemlich viele
da sind und ja auf jeden fall cool es
ist allemal da sind und dass das projekt
eigentlich ja dazu erzählen jetzt alle
mal ein bisschen was also ich fange mal
an indem ich sage es wird ein sehr sehr
klares nein also spaß beiseite es wird
folgendermaßen seien wir alle aber es
könnte vielleicht sogar mehr weit sein
bis es startet man weiß es noch nicht
ganz genau es ist nicht alles so fest
wie es ist es können sogar noch mehr
werden könne wenn wie es halt passt und
die wähler könnten eigentlich fände so
und wir werden eine folge falle seiner
stirn es gibt keine regel weniger claus
wendt ein gemeinsames server eröffnen
auf dem nur youtuber spielen das heißt
ein server auf dem wir alle im
survival-modus sind und auf dem wir uns
gemeinsam oder auch gegeneinander eine
riesige welt aufbauen also es wird ein
server sein wie ein ganz normaler
spieler servern als normaler display
server auf der eine ganz neue welt ist
vielleicht mit irgendwelche speziellen
mods noch drauf das ist also nicht ganz
so fest vielleicht sowas wie viel speed
oder text oder so drauf ist es also ich
ganz fest
und auf diesem server gibt es eigentlich
nur eine richtige regel nämlich
aufnahmepflicht das heißt egal was auf
dem server macht es muss aufgenommen
werden das heißt ihr könnt egal was
passiert du kannst auf allen kanälen
verfolgen so es heißt auch nicht dass
wir alle mal zu acht aufnehmen also c
dur zu zwölft weil es kommen mehr leute
über das projekt dazu wollte man dort
ein dann sind auch fest in unserem
server bleiben können aber wir können
aufnehmen wann und wie wollen wir kommen
ist aber allein aufnehmen
die kräftigsten zu dritt zu viert und
wir können die leute und die aufnahmen
gruppe immer weg sind
das heißt wenn es jetzt mal den er sagt
ihr seid alle scheiße man leider auf und
dieser ist schon bei folge 10 weil er
ein stück aufgenommen hat und sage mal
lud komme sind schon bei sind erst bei
folge drei da und dann will aber weder
was die jugend kommt dann ist es bei der
folge 11 und wenn du gekommen ist es vom
das heißt wir richtung kahlschlag die
anderen das in folge haben sondern wir
sind praktisch dieser welt für uns offen
also wir sind auf uns gestellt wir
können zusammen aufnehmen müssen es aber
nicht
und alles was passiert werde ich aber
trotzdem auf allen kanälen sozusagen
verfolgen können was jetzt
wahrscheinlich erstmal viele denken
werden dass das tier der server ist auf
dem wir spielen werden nein es ist
natürlich schon eine normale welt und
wir werden eventuell auch irgendeinen
gegen eine modifikation draufpacken bzw
ganz viele modifikationen wodurch das
ganze spiel noch mal ein bisschen
erweitert wird
oder halt mit der zeit drauf packen wir
sind halt sehr flexibel
ja also wir erreichten kleine 1
vielleicht ein kleiner anreiz für alle
leute also es wird auch so was wie
fallen mods geben das heißt es kann
natürlich auch gefreut werden aber dann
verschärften man sich natürlich auch
also werden nicht irgendwie sagen der
pvp es aus oder blöcke sind geschützt
das heißt man kann alles klauen man
könnte theoretisch alles der stürmer
kann sich auch bekämpft man kann bei
einer klappe sagt aber es wird natürlich
so sein wenn es kein gesetz gibt es
steht irgendwann erschien das heißt
irgendwann ist der chaos deswegen müssen
wir uns irgendwo eine demokratie
aufbauen werden also gemeinsam beraten
müssen wir werden gemeinsam ja so was
wie vielleicht ja richter ernennen
müssen polizei oder sommer
oder müssen wir es auch strafbar stell
dir vor es wird vom handy statt grün
oder weiß und ist auf jeden fall nicht
politisch
es wird immer es wird immer mehr leute
zu komplex ist kann sein start ist
vielleicht zu acht oder zehn mal gucken
bis zum start dabei sind und am ende
oder was heißt am ende ist es ja eine
offen
später in ein oder zwei monaten sind die
flächen 50 leute und dann haben eine
riesige besiedlung und man nimmst du
alleine auf damit alle 102 anderen oder
mit drei anderen aber trifft wäre eine
aufnahme andere leute die auch gerade
aufsehen weil immer alle nehmen ja auf
das heißt wenn man jemandem sommer
trifft weiß man meist auch eine aufnahme
von anderen obwohl magath für den
aufnimmt so dass im endeffekt so wie
auch damals ist es du hast die big
brother in minecraft immer verfolgen was
wir gerade machen
simon wie oft kommt erni das projekt ja
dieses projekt wie gesagt es kann jeder
selber entscheiden wann und wie ihr
aufnimmt es ist nur wichtig dass man
aufnimmt
das heißt es kann sein dass bei mir
vielleicht jeden tag gefolgt von crafter
es kann selbst bekomme vielleicht nur
einmal wochen erfolgt kommt dabei es ist
schon so dass wir natürlich wollen dass
alle möglichst stabiles und auf lager
haben aber es ist niemand verpflichtet
jeden tag oder in zwei tag aufzunehmen
also und dann kann es natürlich auch
unter gewissen umständen zu kommen das
dann beim 1
die folge wenn zwei zusammen aufnehmen
vielleicht am dienstag kommt und beim
anderen am donnerstag das sollte
eigentlich kein problem darstellen
dann sieht man halt zweimal zeit zwar
mit der verstand sicht und dann wartet
man halt bei dem ein bisschen ist es
dann da ist das sind halt so probleme da
konnte man nichts gegen machen also wir
haben uns echt eine lange zeit darüber
diskutiert wie wir diese kleinen
problemchen und schwierigkeiten aus der
welt schaffen können aber wir haben uns
einfach gedacht das sollte für euch kein
problem sein ihr seid ihr alle cool
drauf und kriegt das wahrscheinlich hin
zu verfolgen und ich hoffe einfach bzw
wir hoffen einfach dass ihr das annehmen
dass ihr das geil findet und wir haben
das ja auch schon in vietze dies gesagt
die mann und ich dass wir so etwas
planen wollen von daher gesehen es ist
ein bisschen viel arbeit weil es welche
wir haben jetzt schon seit ich habe weil
ich eigentlich monaten wirklich nach
richtigen aus pläne ausgaben alles genau
machen führt da immer so ein dokument wo
er mal sein trägt alles nicht eintragen
können zurück also es wirklich sehr sehr
gut starten wir wollen es nicht irgendwo
einfach so dass starten wir sind immer
noch sozusagen dabei ist natürlich auch
jetzt sein dass das vielleicht jetzt
paar leute die idee gut findet auch
machen also kein problem
ich sag mal so es kann ja jeder auch
deswegen wollte ich so früh bekannt
geben aber es kann jeder das machen was
ihr wollt nicht nur sagen was für ein
vorhaben das wird doch vorher noch ein
trailer kommen ich sag mal es so
frühestens dann wird frühestens starten
also es wird schon mitbekommen ja wenn's
doch rentenzeit wollen's gar keine gar
keine zeitspanne setzen wir mit wenn wir
jetzt sagen würden ja in einer woche
startet und dann haben wir vielleicht
auch sehr wenig zeit dann muss das alles
nicht so dann wird das alles nicht so
toll wenn wir als direkt mit anfangen
würden nur weil wir das jetzt gesagt
haben sondern wir werden uns da
natürlich schon ein bisschen arbeiten
mitmachen mit trailer mit bestimmten
sachen halt mitwelt aufbau mit
modifikationen und was als etwa wenn wir
schon gedanken machen und ihr werdet
dann halt ihr werdet schon mit kriegen
wenn das kommt und dann denke ich mal
wird das alles gut geregelt sein und ihr
ich hoffe mal bzw wir hoffen dass ihr
diese schau dann noch annehmen werdet
weil ich glaube das wird eine menge spaß
machen vor allem wenn wir dann alle
zusammen auf einem server sind und dann
links aus also ich denke jeder von uns
denkt es für uns alle spaß und auch für
die zuschauer spaß man wird der punkt
ist warum das video jetzt warum wir
jetzt hier unser projekt schon
preisgeben dass wir gerne von euch
natürlich doch vorschläge bekommen
wollen was für mods ihr euch unbedingt
wünschen würde also ich sag mal so es
ist ein projekt wo wir die zuschauer der
stadt einbinden wollen und wir wollen
natürlich dann auch von anfang an von
anfang an möchten eure meinungen wollen
also ihr können mitbestimmen
hey was trotz oder was wird für euch
sachen die unbedingt dabei sein müssen
was wohl denkt ihr event wenn so viele
youtuber zusammenarbeiten was darf da
nicht fehlen oder so oder ich würde noch
mal gerne jeden vielleicht zu wort
kommen lassen so was ihr euch von dem
projekt denn oft was hier besonders
reizvoll findet weswegen ihr euch
entschieden habt mitzumachen
ich kann es für meinen teil sagen ich
hab mich gefreut so wie simon das gesagt
hat einfach mal diese dafür zu sorgen
dass keine anarchie ausbricht man
einfach das macht was man will man ist
zwanglos man kann aufnehmen mit wem man
will wann man will aber wichtig ist
alles wird aufgenommen
das fand ich halt einfach super das wird
dann auch sein komplettes bild das ich
möchte mich jetzt einfach mal zu wort
also ich finde ich habe schon gesagt
dass sie mich total drauf weil einfach
alles zusammen spielen mit dem man sonst
mal so paar sachen aufnimmt also chronik
ist er dann auch noch dabei der ist halt
nicht im wieder dabei aber wir nehmen
halt wirklich immer alle zusammen auf
das ihr könnt bei jedem sehen wie der
seinen fortschritt hat wendet wenn er
zum beispiel zwei leute zusammen
aufnehmen oder der eine läuft am haus
von anderen vorbei und dessen riesige
einschussloch irgendwie gewesen
dieser hass ist in der heizplatte dann
guckt man bald zum beispiel den vorbei
dann sieht man oder die nacht aus
versehen das 10
wer sich zuhause gezündet anstatt beim
gespielt und dann fällt man das halt
alles so oft das ist halt der vorteil an
dass wir alle aufnehmen und ihr habt da
dann auch so eine show wo ihr euch denkt
so hey guck mal wenn heute bei dem kommt
zwar keine folgen da kann ich weiterhin
sechs anderen leuten die folge gucken
ihr habt da wirklich immer eine menge zu
gucken wenn ihr einfach langeweile habt
also das nimmt an sich nur eine globale
riegel und dieses es da zwar geträumt
werden aber alles und aufgaben das wird
ganz wichtig und wird auch nicht
gebrochen den akkustand ich wollte ihn
nicht
kein problem ja was was nicht noch an
dem projekt was so gut dass man kann
auch ein ganz normales let's play
sozusagen draus machen nur dass dann ein
paar hundert meter 100 blöcke entfernt
noch die anderen auch gleichzeitig
spielen dass so ein bisschen interaktion
stattfinden
denn jeder kann so sein eigenes ding
aufbauen man kann die sachen von anderen
kaputt machen oder aber halt nicht
übertreiben wie cap schon gesagt hat das
heißt ich dich glaubt hält sich jeder
orden nicht an die regeln verdirbt den
spaß sich gegenseitig wird auf jeden
fall
lustig halte ich mich will ich
vorschlagen waren der stelle hier zu
wort denn ich finde bei dem projekt
gerade diese flexibilität richtig toll
dass man hier wie ihr schon eigentlich
dauert tausend mal gesagt habt dass man
hier mit jedem aufnehmen kann und auch
dass ich das ganze noch weiterentwickeln
kann wir wissen nicht ob wir das noch
mit anderen youtuber in zukunft machen
wollen wahrscheinlich schon
und das hört sich immer so weiter
entwickeln und gerade gesagt das prinzip
halt von so einer stadt oder zum start
zum eigenen stadt in wir halt wir
gründen gerade das bin ich einfach nur
hammer und auch das trainerteam erlaubt
es finde ich auch richtig geil aber das
wichtige dabei ist natürlich immer noch
dass man gesetze hat und die sollte man
sich auch halten und da müssen wir
natürlich noch mal schauen wie wir diese
demokratie auch hier führen werden
der mega gau also bei mir ich bin
eigentlich ihr habt schon alles gesagt
es ist echt krass
aber ich mir gefällt es halt auch an
sich dass man wirklich wir uns alle eine
stadt aufbauen und die hat wirklich alle
zusammen sind und hat man immer mit
verschiedenen leuten aufnehmen kann und
dennoch halt alles aufgenommen wird man
halt alles sieht von jedem und das
gefällt mir eigentlich alles ziemlich
und mich ich habe ihr habt schon alles
gesagt das ist nichts was ich noch mal
ganz kurz ergänzen wollte bzw
sagen wollte wollen würde keine ahnung
dass man dann ja auch immer diesen troll
faktor der spielte man eine bestimmte
rolle und zwar wenn zum beispiel der
eine ganz viele diamanten findet dann
macht er sich natürlich eine ändert es
und versteckt die dann irgendwo und
packte dann seine sachen rein oder wenn
er sich eine ganz normale jazz macht
dann versteckte die halt irgendwo
allerdings ist dann halt wieder auf die
voraussetzung dass wir gegenseitig
vielleicht nicht die videos von den
anderen gucken das würde ich jetzt noch
so vorschlagen mal eben weil das wäre
irgendwie ein bisschen witz wenn einer
dann seine sachen versteckte deine tnt
callebaut eine andere sieht das
allerdings wenig jetzt aufnehme dann
laufe ich dann lieber nicht rein weil
aber die mit dem gerät aber ich denke
mal dass da wird da wir das wie so oft
auf aufbauen und es so viele folgen gibt
müsste man sich ja als andere youtuber
wieder so viel angucken um das überhaupt
zu sehen
es ist schon so ein schutz da also auch
wenn jemand der anderen folgen guckt ich
denke mal sucht also alles kann man
nicht von anderen sehen und deswegen
also ich bin da zuversichtlich dass da
nicht irgendwie das durch zurück
verboten sollte es nicht sein aber genau
das was du meintest das gezielte
angucken von speziellen folgen von
beschwor um die küsten nur um die kisten
zu kümmern das ist ja relativ unfair und
aber das ist ja deswegen muss der jenige
der einwände zuschauer das sehen die
zuschauer sind es damit sozusagen auch
die polizei ein bisschen sie sehen dass
wenn jemand zum beispiel das cloud und
sie das direkt einfach hingegangen weil
es sich im video angeschaut hat dann
schreiben wir es einfach 3000 mal in die
kommentare oder sagen demjenigen dem das
geklaute bescheid und dann wird ein
gerichtsurteil vom richter komme gefällt
oder das und ich bin auch ich bin der
harz leute ich verstehe ja keinen spaß
ich werd ich erläutere ich würde ja
harte richtlinien walten lassen und wenn
hier jemand dazu hat rollt dann komme
ich ja verstehen dass es echte des
projektes und dass man mit den leuten
mit dem man auch sowieso schon etwas zu
tun hat oder auch nicht das man besser
zusammenarbeitet und zwei kann also ist
denke ich ein ziemlich cooles projekt
längst auch und ich würde am ende noch
gerne sagen das was der herrscher
anspruch hat also das möchte das wird
die zuschauer als die polizei in dem
sinne also als ordnungshüter brauchen
das ist ein sehr wichtiger bestandteil
vom projekt also ihr wirklich müsst
immer sozusagen den anderen von die
rückmeldung wiedergeben über andere also
wenn jemand sich als 200 oder so einen
scheiß gebaut hat dann ist er durchaus
passen also deswegen ist es auch gut
dass ihr überall bei allen kanälen
vorbei schauen könnt also ihr könnt ja
sozusagen sozusagen alles dorte das ist
das lustiges wegen ist es gut wenn jeder
aufnimmt und
auch gut finde ist dass jetzt gerade
vergessen zu sagen das war jetzt diese
diskussion im umbruch am wochenende das
ist diese grüppchen gibt so weiter und
gerade mit dem hier ja also gerade damit
wollen wir diese diese gruppen irgendwie
verbrechen weil wie gesagt wir laden hat
also dann wirklich alle also wir
entscheiden dann wer reinkommt dass
jetzt alle mindest zuschauer denken ja
ich gehe darum auf dem server und dem
damit genau es ist das wichtig ist es
war einfach alles place mit der qualität
wir wollen jetzt gleichsam nur let's
play mit 10.000 abos also quatsch
auch kleinere lecks player wenn die uns
überzeugen der punkt ist dass auch jetzt
hier ganz viele dort hinzukommen können
zu servern an
wer definiert hinzu kommen und auch ich
sag mal ja also bedeutet mit dem wir bis
jetzt noch nie was gemacht haben und ich
freue mich auf jeden fall auf die neuen
kontakte ich freue mich auf dieses
riesige projekt auch mit euch ein und
ich glaube es wird einfach richtig
lustig und ich würde einfach sagen
als erste infos dass das getan wenn es
vor dem trailer noch eine info gibt
jetzt eher sehen
ansonsten freut sich die trailer und
freut euch dann auf das projekt übrigens
als kleine info
wir sind hier übrigens auf gab es 92 h
verraten ja ganz komisch da steht auch
irgendwie komme drin weiß ich mir das
passieren konnte
auf einmal bin wo ich mit dir sachen
ausgerüstet fertig nicht veröffentlicht
alles noch streng geheim
natürlich einfach sagen und dann beim
nächsten mal schreibt eure schreibt eure
vorschläge und eure wünsche für mods und
für andere ideen noch die fabrik die
hand sind aber ihr wollt macht ist ja
dass die filme plate angeeignet und
genau ich es packen also für plug ist
aber wichtig ist auch wir wollen einfach
unsere zuschauer selbst einbindung wir
wollen einfach dass die
entscheidungsfreiheit wir wollen nicht
einfach jetzt von heute auf morgen
starten ohne anzukündigen
wir wollen sich so schnell wirklich
jetzt einfach starten und raus hauen wir
wollen einfach dass ihr mit teil davon
sei das ist ganz wichtig für uns
ist eine lassen das ist nicht so ein
server ist wohl nur wir drauf sind
sondern dass ihr auch indirekt mit
darauf sind wir natürlich die folgen von
den anderen sieht und dann könnt ihr zu
sagen hey guck mal der hatten leuchtturm
gebaut willst du da nicht auch mal
fragen ob du dich rein gehen kannst
damit du uns das auch aus deiner sicht
zeigt wieder von dir aussieht oder
irgendwie so was sehen wir daher
wirklich alle zusammen connected sind
wir stehen natürlich auch immer zusammen
der beschreibung dass sie dann auch mal
die aktuellsten folgen bei den anderen
leuten sehen können wenn euch zb fragt
wer ist das da der in diesem jahr grüne
t shirt anna damit ich auch mal ganz
gern vorbeigucken und dann kann man
alles erarbeiten das wäre ja dann wie
gesagt bis zum nächsten video und wasser